all right we have a hatred mail this
week patriot mail your break from the
tyranny of unbiased independent media
because knowledge and information are
just communist conspiracies patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
all right this Patriot mail is going to
relate to some ongoing themes on the
show I'll present it without any further
introduction and then we can discuss I
would like to see this gay dweeb
confined to live in a neighborhood with
Muslims he loves so much after they
string him up or throw him off a balcony
for being a homosexual perhaps they will
realize why most of us hate these
[ __ ] and want them to go back from
whatever [ __ ] they came from yeah
I'm sort of over exploring why there's
so much focus on my perceived sexual
orientation that we've done ad nauseam
on the show the interesting thing for me
here basically two things number one
this is an appeal to emotion right if
only I went to these so-called Muslim
neighborhoods as a supposed gay man
which you know we dealt with that before
then I would change my view about
something and this is sort of like well
you would before the death penalty if
someone you loved was killed and I I
would actually argue decisions made in
the heat of emotion are not actually how
we should dictate any kind of national
policy that's number one but of course
the other thing that this voicemail
seems to ignore is that we've been
hugely critical of radical Islam and
we've been hugely critical of the fact
that radical radical Islam number one is
a term that I'm willing to use number
two radical Islam is not good for women
it's not good for members of the LGBT
community
it's almost lewis like hey tree it's
right in an entire email based only on
one sentence i might have at some point
said without considering our broader
points on the subject that that might be
shocking i don't know it happens all the
time or just one story someone will see
one story and from that one story one
youtube segment they understand
everything about us
in the show if you're gonna write me
this pond scum garbage these loser
critiques at least make them based on
what we say on the show not some
half-baked analysis based on hearing two
seconds and by the way I have a special
membership coupon code I want to turn
hate reott mail into something positive
that helps the show as opposed to just
hate so you can use coupon code hate
reott for tha t RI ot for zero this will
work 20 times at david pakman.com slash
membership and we'll give you really
nice solid discount off of membership
it's the best way I can think of to turn
hate reott ism into something positive
for the show